فلماذا أرادت حكومة مارش بشكل أساسي
وضع هدف كبير وهدف طموح
أمام شبابها الذين
يراقبونهم وأيضًا إرسال رسالة كما
ذكرت سابقًا إلى الشباب العربي
ألهمتهم للدخول في العلوم
والتكنولوجيا لذلك هناك  الأهداف من
وراء المهمة التي ترتبط
بدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة وهي أيضًا أهداف علمية ،
لذا فنحن إذا
نظرت إليها علميًا ، فإن السبب وراء
استكشاف البشرية للمريخ هو أن العلماء
يعتقدون أن الكوكب ربما كان
نقطة معينة مشابهة للأرض وفي
ومع ذلك ، فقد وصلت هذه الميزة إلى
النقطة التي بدأت فيها تفقد
ميزته وجزء كبير
منها هو في الواقع
فقدان غلافه الجوي ، لذا فإن
الفهم الأفضل لما حدث على المريخ
يمكن أن يساعدنا في فهم
التغييرات التي يمكن أن تحدث بشكل أفضل
يحدث في جميع أنحاء كوكبنا ، إنه شهر مزدحم
بالنسبة إلى كوكب المريخ ، حيث تتنافس الإمارات العربية المتحدة
مع الولايات المتحدة والصين ، وكلاهما
يطلق مهمات مماثلة في هذا اليوم.
لدى كل من mmer موارد هائلة ، يجب أن
يقال كيف تأمل
أن تبرز مهمتك وما الذي
سيبدو عليه النجاح بالنسبة لك ما قد يشكل
اكتشافًا كبيرًا للاكتشاف يا سيدي ،
لذا فإن الاضطرابات المذكورة من قبل أن
برنامج الفضاء هو أكثر من وسيلة
وأداة لتحقيق هدف أكبر بكثير ، لذا فإن الذهاب إلى
كوكب المريخ ليس الهدف الرئيسي
هنا ، إنه يتعلق بتحفيز
القطاعات المختلفة واستخدام هذه المهمة
كمحفز لتغيير مدمر في
القطاع الأكاديمي والقطاع الاقتصادي
وقطاعات داسارا ، لذلك
أرادت الحكومة تسريع
التغيير في القطاعات المستقلة التي أردت
إنشاء ثقافة البحث والتطوير بين
الشباب وجعلهم يتجهون إلى وضع حد لذلك هذا ما
نظرت إليه في كوكب المريخ ، لذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمقارنة بما قد تفعله الدول الأخرى
، فعادة ما يكون التركيز فقط  في العلوم
بالنسبة لنا ، يتعلق الأمر بالعلم ولكنه أيضًا
يتعلق بأهداف أخرى